welcome to the man of recaps this is the
walking dead season 11 episode 9. yes
the walking dead is back we're now in
part two of the three-part final season
episode eight ended on a cliffhanger as
leah and the reapers had just fired the
huacha at our crew and this thing is
even cooler than i thought because these
rocket-propelled arrows then explode
but while it does take out a bunch of
the walkers it is not that effective on
the humans none of our gang get hit they
managed to get inside the buildings and
now the big reaper battle is a sneaky
sneaking around fight the other
cliffhanger was back at alexandria which
is currently under a zombie invasion and
it's little judith grimes and gracie who
are trapped in the flooding basement but
daddy aaron's coming to save him he
jumps down there and gets the girls to
safety but now he's stuck down there and
for the first time in a long time we've
got walkers in the water well long story
short he puts in work it's exhausting
but he's trying to climb on out of there
finally it's lydia who we haven't seen
in a while that brings him a rope and
helps him out of there now back to the
reapers daryl has an epic knife fight
with this one and yeah he wins then
father gabriel finds the reaper's priest
and it's finally time for a preach-off
now gabriel's been a great character
lately as he's been losing his faith as
things keep getting worse the reaper
priest has no doubts he's like yeah man
god talks to me all the time i know what
i'm doing is right so put your weapons
down and let's be friends a while back
gabriel would have been right there with
him but now oh stops this guy yeah
father gabriel's now on that old
testament sam jackson and pulp fiction i
will smite you with my righteous wrath
kind of father the rest of our gang
ambushes this one reaper who apparently
is the one that killed elijah's sister
he's also apparently the best fighter of
the whole bunch they've taken down
others solo no problem but this guy's
fighting three of them he's a beast in
the end negan picks up a bell then
throws some pocket sand at the guy and
clocks him oh what a weird weapon elijah
wants to kill him to avenge his sister
but just then daryl shows up like hold
on let's take him hostage so it's time
to negotiate both sides are down to just
four people now and daryl channels his
inner rick grimes hey we've all survived
this far we shouldn't be killing each
other but leah has a sniper on the roof
oh now she's got the advantage but wait
what's this he shoots the reaper's leg
because it's father gabriel up there oh
yeah so now our crew has the advantage
again it's like you guys get on out here
we'll let you live but maggie remembers
how the reapers came in and massacred
all of her people with no mercy and
maggie has a change of heart it's an
epic scene with intense music as she
goes over there and shoots them in the
back oh no mercy from maggie she's not
messing around daryl tracks down leah
who survived and it's like i'm so sorry
about this i wish we could have been
friends but not in the guards and so it
took eight episodes but our crew has
succeeded in their mission to get more
food for alexandria now that the
danger's over maggie goes back to the
church where they left alden but
unfortunately alden didn't make it r.i.p
alden while she's burying him negan
comes up looking menacing it's like look
mags i know we kind of made some
progress in the first part of the season
and you promised you wouldn't kill me
but i just watched you break that
promise to the reapers and i'm kind of
thinking one day you're gonna do it to
me too but he's not here to fight it out
right now he's like i guess this group
isn't big enough for both of us i'll
just be on my way and so negan leaves
the group going off on his own what
adventures await him juargenk makes it
back to alexandria and everyone's
reunited our full crew together for the
first time in a while daryl finds out
connie's alive this is a great reunion
they kind of got a romance and don't
forget father gabriel and rosita are
together so they're reunited too but
negan of course is missing from this
reunion and nobody particularly misses
him except lydia who was really tight
with him he's her uncle negan and now
it's like what he just left on his own
but now what's this someone else is
coming who's that riding down the road
oh it's the commonwealth stormtroopers
but they're not here for a fight eugene
busts out like hey we're all friends and
lance hornsby gives them the welcome
speech what's up everyone we're from the
commonwealth we're super cool and
definitely not secretly evil eugene told
us alexandria was a really great
settlement but it kind of looks like
it's seen better days so it's up to you
guys we can give you foreign aid and
help you rebuild here or you can come
join us at the commonwealth which is not
destroyed and has ice cream it's an
interesting offer daryl looks over to
maggie to see what she thinks and whoa
oh god it was a match cut maggie's back
at the hilltop and it's six-month time
jump commonwealth stormtroopers are at
her gates maggie's like it doesn't have
to be this way and this one trooper
reveals his helmet oh it's our boy daryl
and he says yeah it does so it looks
like pretty soon we're gonna get daryl
versus maggie how did we get here why is
maggie at the hilltop why did daryl join
the commonwealth and why did he not get
a haircut find out in the rest of the
walking dead season 11 part 2.
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member